in Tanzania gay and transgender people
have gone into hiding this comes after
the government announced a crackdown on
homosexuals
now same-sex conduct is punishable by up
to 30 years in prison in Tanzania and as
of tomorrow
a special committee will seek to
identify and punish members of the LGBT
community
well max and from our news days has been
following that story and is with me in
studio now so max what is going on in
Tanzania so first of all government
official Palma khandhas announced his
plan targeting gay people earlier this
week at a press conference and it
involves setting up a task force
dedicated to tracking gay people down
and detaining them and he has also asked
the public to take part in this and
calling at call out individuals who they
believe are a gay and despite
international criticism he is not up for
discussing or debating this issue has
made very clear at the press conference
let's have a look at what he had to say
if you think gays have a right take them
and stay with them in your countries
because they can come to you and tell
you we're not needed in Tanzania or dar
es salaam so mr. makanda using very
strong language there what's the
reaction bin
well there's a lot of support for the
LGBT community in Tanzania the UN Human
Rights Commission issued this statement
on Twitter here they write the call on
try to track and arrest gay people in
Tanzania and to encourage reports
against those suspected of being gay
could turn into a license for bullying
and violence against the LGBT and the
deputy prime minister of Ireland even
brought up for an aide and a possible as
a possible consequence to the government
crackdown he tweeted targeting of LGBT
community is shocking and I've written
to the government to outline my concerns
so is there a way that users on social
media can protect themselves yes there
is and the US government has brought
that up the US Embassy and Arthur Salam
issued this statement on their website
here it says review internet footprint
and social media profiles remove or
protect images and language that may run
afoul of Tanzanian laws regarding
homosexual practices and explicit sexual
activity
some of more concrete advice this
Twitter user had to share and where it
says one of the things the person
recommends is changing of the location
setting the account to private and
blocking quote creepy accounts that you
don't know and this post here was
retweeted more than 20,000 times so
there are ways to protect your identity
online but it goes without saying the
internet does not forget and content you
shared in the past or messages you wrote
to other users they are still out there
I might sell out then people who you
shared this conflict with might still
have access to it and it's up to them if
they use it against you or not max and I
thank you